episode one The episode begins with the
Escape of a dangerous convict named
Damien Tillman from a Maximum Security
Prison he does this by sneaking beneath
a pickup truck using license plates he
had collected over the past month the
U.S Marshals led by Rey zanelli and
Charlie Duchamp begin a Manhunt to find
Damien and bring him back into custody
to Aid in the search zancanelli and
Duchamp decide to form a special task
force consisting of convicts who have a
talent for breaking out of prison the
team includes Lloyd Lowry a former child
prodigy Shaya Daniels a skillful Thief
Philly a beautiful but cunning con
artist and Gunderson the muscles
together the team uses their unique
skills to track down Damien and bring
him back into custody before he can
cause any more harm throughout the
episode viewers see the team working
together to gather Clues and track down
leads while also dealing with their own
struggles to escape in the end they can
successfully capture Damien and return
him to prison but not before facing many
challenges and obstacles along the way
episode 2. in the second episode
collected the team is ordered to track
down price Xavier a happy family man
with jail time for accidentally killing
a robber according to his wife and his
record price is completely clean but
something about him doesn't sit right
with Lloyd later in the episode we can
see Xavier acting suspiciously and going
around from town to town as time goes by
we can see Lloyd's suspicions coming
true he had suspected that price had a
hobby of collecting women due to his
past trauma it has proven true when they
find women trapped in certain properties
owned by Xavier a new character Erica
Reed is introduced replacing Philly
because of her they were able to catch
price at the right time and all the
women were brought to safety the episode
ends with shap and Rey deciding on
whether Erica should stay on the team or
not Ray tests her which she passes and
they decide to let her stay episode 3 in
another prison a man named Theodore
Bagwell escapes while being transported
from medical examination he escapes
while being transported according to
reports Bagwell was imprisoned for
killing teenagers Shaya being familiar
with such a pattern informs the team
about it to which they all ignore him
still on the Run Theodore kills eight
people including his ex-wife and her
husband the team finally circles him to
a hospital where his mother Mrs Bagwell
was admitted they are informed about
this by the owner of a nursing home
where Mrs Bagwell was previously staying
they succeeded in cornering him and
capturing him after he bids his mother
farewell later in the episode Lloyd can
be seen interviewing him one-on-one and
declares that there was no fixing this
man episode 4. in this episode code
Joseph Ramsey an accused sex offender is
seen escaping prison by stealing a TV
Cruise jacket he is really skillful with
how he escapes later Erica is seen being
mad about the team calling her in during
visitation hours with a foul mood she
tries to carry on with the investigation
Joseph is seen to have a Dangerous Aura
that alarms kids around him the team
investigates Joseph's case they make an
End route to a playground where Joseph
is seen with an eight-year-old the girl
seems to be petrified and is taken into
police custody meanwhile Erica chases
after Joseph losing him in the process
the police tried questioning tests to
see if he had made any advances towards
her she doesn't give an answer about the
way Tess's father reacts to throwing
Lloyd off they interviewed Joseph's
ex-wife later on Joseph visits his
lawyers and presumably attacks him to
which the police along with the team
arrive at the scene a pattern is set
which helps the police track down Joe
they nearly catch him but Charlie loses
him at the subway injured Lloyd is
ordered to stay with Julianne while with
her he figures that Joseph was not the
perpetrator but the victim Lloyd and
Julianne visit Tess one more time to ask
her about what was causing her distress
without getting answers he still
proceeds to convince Charlie of Joseph's
innocence but he is still arrested in
the office Tess visits with her mom and
it is known that indeed Joseph was a
victim and the real Predator was Tess's
father the episode ends with Charlie
bringing Erica to her daughter episode 5
this episode is called Queen of Hearts
the scene opens up with an inmate being
released to move to meet the prison
guard she tricks him and threatens him
with his son's picture getting clothed
she manages to escape through a prison
van in the next scene Lloyd loses a game
of poker and is in debt of 800 US
dollars they go to work and find out
that the escaped inmate 8 Lyla Thompson
had stabbed her second husband her first
husband was killed in a house fire the
only family she is left with is her 14
year old son Taylor who is under Federal
care so Lila does not harm him the team
is visited by the prison guard where he
gets Lila's stuff Charlie and Ray
question him about their relationship
and how Lila had gotten an outfit the
guard refuses their suspicion he tells
them that the phone was given by someone
else he informs them of how Lila was
planning to go on a cruise and they
order her mug shot to be broadcasted
throughout the nation one of her victims
the owner of a go-karting Club gets his
bank account emptied Julianne tracks the
transactions Lila gets alerted when she
sees her mug shot at a store the team
visits Lila's son Taylor he assures to
contact them as soon as his mom contacts
him not convinced Lloyd requested to see
the kid alone and he tells him about not
trusting him but gives him his phone
number la Isla is seen with another guy
whom she shoots after a little Coral her
pen pals are called and interviewed
separately they fail until Erica gets
Lila's number from one of her pen pals
receiving Lila's phone records they find
out she is in contact with Taylor and he
goes missing in New Jersey she is seen
at her ex's house who refuses to keep
her with him she shoots him and moves to
a trailer Taylor calls Lloyd informing
him about his mom's odd behavior the
police surround the trailer and Lila is
taken down episode 6 at the start of
this episode inmate Christian can be
seen making something with a light bulb
in the next scene he is seen with his
lawyer asking for a break he breaks out
of prison by using the light bulb bomb
being a hurt sympathizer he thinks that
the government is corrupt the
psychiatrist informs them about his
condition Christian had both severe rage
disorder and acute persecution complex
Lloyd does not agree with his methods
and disagree trees by giving such a
convect Uprising book the team is
informed about it and they get to know
that Christian blamed the government for
his mother passing away and his father
agreed with it Rai and the crew reach
Christian's dad's house and they find
burnt patches of grass concluding that
Christian was present due to his
knowledge of the law the Christian
father kicks them out meanwhile
Christian blows a postal office on their
arrival the team finds out fertilizer is
being used next Julian informs them
about a fertilizer company and upon
reaching the owner doesn't cooperate
they find 40 missing fertilizers
anointed deschamp Christian sends a bomb
to his wife alerted they speed up the
process to look for him at a protest
they find the government official that
had been helping Christian they are
close to catching him but he runs away
from his Hideout Lloyd figures out
Christian's position and they Rush with
a bomb squad Christian is found and the
bomb is defused episodes 7. on
visitation day Marlon O'Connell is
visited by his mother who he later kills
to escape he takes another person
hostage named Starla Roland whom the
police suspect to be helping Mars rise
into shop visit starla's mother who
clarifies their suspicion of Mars and
Starla working together on the other
hand Starla and Mars opened fire in a
restaurant to lay low Starla and Mars
moved to the Highland where another man
is found dead with his car keys stolen
later they shot a sheriff on duty taking
his gun with them Mars's inmate is
questioned and he tells them about his
advice the runners are seen in a house
where they have tied up the family the
team finds the car and figures that they
might be hiding in the high-end
residential area they catch Starla by
tracking transactions but she turns the
situation around and she captures Lloyd
and rice meanwhile Shaya along with
Duchamp America find the location and
they are rescued episode 8 a 50 pound
plus male is poisoned to death the body
of the man however is replaced by two
convicts day and McCann it is found that
they had been communicating through a
book race tries to interview day's
sister but she does not cooperate day
kills a man on the other hand while
McCann draws money Julian informs the
others later the team checks the scene
out and finds the Dead Guy day in McCann
can later be seen in a motel after which
they break into a guy's house the 85
year old is found dead and his car is
missing meanwhile the car runs out of
gas Charlie and the team search the area
around the car being really close to
catching them at a pharmacy
Unfortunately they lose them they seem
to reach a house where according to day
had 100 Grand in his house the house
turns out to be an ex-convict who was
day's ex-inmate he seems to have abused
days both sexually and physically he
wanted to take revenge for his 18 year
old self the episode ends with days
being captured as he realized what he
had done episode 9 prisoner Brennan
Andre escapes with the help of a
duplicate key and his mates inside the
prison the prison guard had provided
Brennan with a duplicate in exchange for
some cash later rice and deschamp visit
Brennan's ex-partner where she assures
them that she had not been in contact
with him but later is proven wrong when
the second time they don't find her in
this entire episode it is seen how the
police along with the team was doing
exactly what Brennan had planned for
them to see this spell is however broken
when Brennan's true love is offered
tissues by Rhys which turns out to be a
tracking device Brendan is arrested
after a full day Chase episode 10 Virgil
Downing a notorious Killer skillfully
escapes prison and is seen to be going
around killing specific teenagers racing
di shampoo a background check and it is
found that most of the murdered people
are found to be connected to the rape
case of Genevieve racinity shop
interview her father who stayed seems to
be knowing nothing about the killer but
seemed unbothered by the murder of the
students as the episode progresses
reason the team predict the last suspect
by asking Genevieve about it she had
confessed earlier about wishing all the
people that were there to be killed and
her father might have taken a liking to
the idea before the murder of the last
suspect recently shops are fast on their
feet and Virgil is captured episode 11 a
schizophrenic psycho named Bennett
bolster runs away after impaling one of
the Watchmen during an outing he had a
previous episode of stalking and killing
a local newscaster while interviewing
one of the patients it is found that
Bennett was after a Hostess Ms Myers who
was engaged to be married Gunderson is
allowed to help in this case and with
him they tracked down where Bennett was
taking her Lloyd narrowed the area down
he finds that Bennett was weirdly
obsessed with birds which helped him
Erica helps Miss Myers Escape but then
is caught Charlie rescues her by
shooting Bennett as he was a equipped
with a weapon episode 12 five of the
most dangerous convicts break out of a
highly secured prison the team is
introduced to the new Chief director
Richard Wendell the escaped convicts are
Ronald Barnes Chester Rhodes Carlos
Cepeda tranjun and Sandy Clement as the
episode progresses all convicts are
found one by one in different locations
that were tipped off by Richard being
The Mastermind he had planned the guise
for having different roles and each one
of them was told a different plan to
tick the police off in different
directions Shaya is sent inside the
prison to find information about this
case where he finds out that Ronald was
going to escape by sea with all the
money that he had stashed up inside one
of his properties he makes his way to
his Escape Route recently Shopper
already at the scene Ronald holds Lloyd
at gunpoint but he is shot by Reese and
arrested episode 13 Carmen Vega also
known as Le Santa a cunning drug Lord
escapes prison while visiting for her
son's funeral the woman seems to be all
put together and naive but is actually
very smart and Sly she had ordered her
oldest to be killed just so she could
Escape her plan was to get her position
back at the top due to her influence
everywhere she got Shaya to be careful
she had his girlfriend captivated later
it is found an Insider is part of
Vanessa's plans the officer kills
himself in guilt on edge the breaking
King convicts worry for their families
by getting a tip Rhys along with the
team break into Carmen's Warehouse where
they capture her son they found a large
number of filters the team captures her
and brings back Shea's girlfriend
deshamp assures the safety of the family
of the other convicts and the season
ends